اعلن حزب الله ان مقاتليه قصفوا بصواريخ
مرابض الجيش الاسرائيلي في ديشون بالاسلحه
الصاروخيه واصابها بشكل مباشر فيما قال
الجيش الاسرائيلي انه رصد اطلاق عده قذائف
نحو مواقعه في منطقه مزارع شبعه صباح
اليوم والاشتباه بتسلل مسيره من لبنان
وذلك نحو مناطق الجليل الاعلى في ساعه
الفجر وافاد مراسلون ان المدفعيه
الاسرائيليه قصفت محيط بلده عيترون جنوب
لبنان كما استهدف الطيران الاسرائيلي ليلا
منزلا في عيترون ما ادى الى تدميره وكان
الجيش قد الاسرائيلي قد اعلن ان طائراته
الحربيه ومدفعيته قصفت عده مناطق داخل
الاراضي اللبنانيه قال انها اهداف وبنى
تحتيه عسكريه تابعه لحزب
الله معنا من ابل السقي جنوب لبنان مراسل
الجزيره ايهاب العقدي
و نبدا مع ك الايهاب اذا حزب الله اعلن
قصف مرابض
الجيش الاسرائيلي في ديشون والجيش
الاسرائيلي يتحدث عن تسلل مسيره من داخل
لبنان هل م تفصيل اكثر حول هذه
التطورات طبعا مربض المدفعيه الذي هاجمه
حزب الله هو المسؤول عن قصف اطراف بلدات
لبنانيه مختلفه وتحديدا في القطاع الاوسط
والغربي يستخدم هذا المربض في عمليات قصف
ممنهجه باتجاه الاراضي اللبنانيه وحاول
حزب الله من خلال قصفه بالصواريخ اسكات
مدافعه التي كانت تطلق نحو المناطق
القريبه من الحدود اللبنانيه لا يعلن حزب
الله عمليا عن اطلاق مسيرات باتجاه
الاراضي الفلسطينيه وتحديدا باتجاه
المناطق القريبه من الحدود الا اذا كانت
لاسباب ترتبط بمهاجمه موقع عسكري حزب الله
كان اطلق عده مرات مسيرات استطلاعيه وصلت
الى مناطق في ال في عمق شمال اسرائيل وهو
ما اعلنه الجانب الاسرائيلي ولم يتحدث عنه
حزب الله الليله الماضيه شهدت ايضا
استمرار الجانب الاسرائيلي بالقصف بواسطه
الغارات الجويه التي استهدفت منزلا في
بلده عيترون الحدوديه اعلن بعد حزب الله
عن نعي احد مقاتليه كان في هذا المنزل
طبعا الطيران الحربي الاسرائيلي كان نشن
سلسله غارات يوم امس مستهدفه مناطق مفتوحه
في جنوب لبنان وتحديدا في القطاع الشرقي
قرب بلده مرجعيون وهي المنطقه التي تعد
منطقه حيويه للمرور بين قضائي حاصبيا
ومرجعيون ومدينه
النبطيه ايضا ايضا هذا الامر استتبع بقصف
مدفعي اسرائيلي صباح هذا اليوم باتجاه
بلده عيترون